Well, as we expected from our picture and from our work earlier on in the
lesson, we got complex numbers as our roots. Now, looking at where the vertex of
our parabola is below the x-axis, and the fact that the parabola is pointing
downward, this curve doesn't really fit the situation that we're interested in.
Remember, that y here in this equation and in this graph, is the vertical
displacement from the ground of the water and x is the horizontal displacement
of the water. Right now, the water is underground and that's not really what
Grant's looking for in terms of decorations. So, what do you think is wrong with
Grant's equation and his graph right now? There's one single thing that we can
do to this graph that would fix the entire problem that we're having. The
mislocation of the horizontal and veritcal coordinates of the water in Grant's
fountain. So, what one step should we do to this graph to make it better
describe that fountain's shape? Should we flip this parabola upside down? Should
we translate it up? Translate it down? Make it wider? Make it skinnier?
Translate it to the right? Translate it to the left? Or just leave it alone
altogether?